agora qual que eu acho engraçado é que
em filme de terror A criança conversa
com diabo a cadeira se mexe só a câmera
filma cor do além e o povo acha normal é
uma mulher pega a câmera para
experimentar passa um vulto tomei um
susto macho Eu tranquei o cu com tanta
força que eu acho que a bosta veio parar
na garganta ô meu Deus Acho que vi algo
estranho Ontem à noite olha o que minha
câmera filmou vejam isso tá lá na tela
da televisão a cara do satanás
desenhadinha parece que até maquiaram oh
meu Deus eu vejo algo estranho ô meu
Deus estou começando a achar que tem
algo estranho com essa casa desgraça Tu
acabou de filmar o satanás foi ainda
acha que tem algo estranho isso aí hein
filme porque na vida real se eu for na
cozinha Se eu for abrir a geladeira a
geladeira demorar dois segundos para
abrir digo meu Deus do céu essa
geladeira tá com demônio chama o pastor
meu Deus eu escolho Deus e eu tiro o
demônio da minha